los bomberos alejan a un hombre herido
que aparece lastimado en el pecho la
escuela fue rápidamente evacuada después
de que el pistolero abriera fuego
adentro más estudiantes salieron poco a
poco de la escuela aturdidos por la
experiencia el ataque tuvo lugar en la
ciudad de
600.000 habitantes al oeste de los
montes urales las imágenes grabadas con
celulares muestran a los estudiantes
refugiándose en su aula mientras se
producía el ataque las autoridades
dijeron que un hombre entró en la
escuela y empezó a disparar
indiscriminadamente antes de atentar
contra sí mismo entre los muertos
lamentan varios niños y al menos un
profesor un desconocido entró en la
escuela mató al Guardia por lo que
sabemos hay otras víctimas algunas de
ellos niños y también heridos la
evacuación ya se ha completado
según estas imágenes publicadas por las
autoridades locales los cartuchos del
tirador fueron encontrados con la
palabra odio en pintura roja y en su
camiseta había una esvástica
el atacante se suicidó se sabe que lleva
una camiseta negra con el símbolo nazi y
una sudadera con capucha no llevaba
ninguna identificación documentos
premiumnos no es la primera vez que en
Rusia se producen tiroteos en institutos
por ahora no se sabe si hay alguna
relación con la Guerra de Ucrania pero
el gobierno ruso lo ha calificado de
acto de terrorismo